it's obviously not something that i'm
looking forward to
you know but it does follow our real
life and
hopefully the viewers will follow us
along the journey and
be kind justin hartley files for divorce
oh my god hi he just blindsided you
i mean she she doesn't deserve this she
is the sweetest girl
um she was so madly in love with him and
and divorce
is hard no matter what i think it's
going to surprise fans how much
is shared and plus on top of that the
reaction that the group has to it
because
there's yeah we're getting started on
that let's let's get started on it
we've got to support her keep our mouths
shut the rest of us are just like
no comment we support her she's the best
i'm not backing anybody up here but i'm
just saying
everyone has their own side in every
situation right i was kind of surprised
to see that my wedding was
used as a location for drama
and as a backdrop for everything else
that was going on
she's our family she is our friend and
so it's her side
we don't know any detail but if you have
been said there's always two sides to
the story to press do you know what that
could do to her we don't know any
details
i didn't even know any of that stuff
went down until
afterwards i was told what happened um
i had no idea what was it like to be
there and see it in real time
it was tough she's wrong she's right and
we support her
that's it but chris to be fair obviously
justin has his own side right can we
stop
that's all i'm saying unfortunately for
divina the editing made it look
very aggressive towards the end but if
you would see the whole conversation it
was
not really like that i was not intending
to offend kirchelle
and i was truly trying to have a
conversation to understand a little bit
so i could relate to the situation and
be
more compassionate it's possible i'm
wrong but you don't see that part of the
conversation
and so it just is edited down to only
look like i'm
just piercing at her which is not what
happened so you don't make comments
against your co-worker and
and friend this is our girl she's our
friend
we protect her no there's no need she's
hurting enough why are you saying well i
don't know what happened it doesn't
matter what
happened protect her you didn't get
married to get divorced
you know you know that right
that's why i i don't want to do this
anymore
she's gonna leave she's gonna leave guys
i was cringing the whole time
were you surprised at how hard davina
went
at her at the wedding i should say no
but i mean i i she always goes hard on
everybody
i couldn't believe she did that at
christine's wedding it was just i mean
it was davina being divina
i mean not really thinking it through or
being sensitive to anyone's feelings
i think i'm my quote unquote
uh villain personality is really
exaggerated and
misunderstood and i think it's really
unfair i think that i'm
very genuine and i'm very honest and um
i stand up for the truth and and if
edited a certain way
then it can look like i'm mean or cold
or rude
and i understand that the audience only
sees what they see
i was baffled and just couldn't even
believe
like is there something wrong really
with your brain
are you talking or is there something
like what is going on
why are you even go like i just couldn't
understand it and then mary's a little
more vocal than me
she wants to have some say she wants to
be a part of it
um like this group and and and she's
not that much um so she just always
tries to insert herself
okay mary that's not true so um it hurts
my feelings but it is what it is
and i'm gonna just move forward i don't
have much to say to her
looking back now i do wish i would have
stood up for christelle in that moment
you're kind of the only person in that
scene who tries to even shut her down
i'll let her go let her go right amanda
should we let her go
i'm gonna michelle
i forgot i even did that until i watched
it back yeah good luck
[Laughter]
good luck with that i literally like to
chase him down i was like
turn the cameras off now leave her alone
like i was i was
so mad because she is i mean she's
hurting
and and yes we agreed to do the show but
i was i'm
i was upset with our producers i was
upset with everyone i was like
make this stuff right now i was like
this is not cool
hold on one second you all right
she's out dude she's
[Music]
woman is hurting and this is like we
were we had like a whole moment which
i'm kind of glad they didn't get that
they didn't show that but we were just
you know mary had her vape i had like an
actual cigarette and i remember the
cameras were there we were really heated
and the producer went and talked to
christelle and like she came back for a
moment but then
i was like damn it like she she was
there
and it took a lot for her to be this was
like
days after her divorce and you're on a
wedding
like right for somebody who you don't
even really care for
you know it was just it was a lot so i
don't know davina was just
i don't know maybe she was hallucinating
you want to be in it and be a villain or
do you want to be
and then not being dead basically right
so
i can sleep at night that's all i can
tell you davina has a line in the finale
that i
that stuck out to me where she says
amanda we want to be there for her but i
don't know if she wants us to be there
for her
you know what i mean i would agree with
that she's hard
she's hard to crack you know um
all the other girls are very open and we
talk about everything with each other
and she's the only one that
kind of doesn't really give it we don't
know anything about i mean none of these
girls know anything about her
maybe marry a little bit but none of the
other girls and it's unfortunate because
we all want to get to know her we tried
you know and i've tried to mend that so
many times and she just shut it down and
shut it down and shut it down and just
you know so christelle does share so
much this season
but i do think fans are going to sit at
the end and wonder what was that final
argument between her
and justin that seemed to set things off
did she have an argument or anything we
had a fight that morning over the phone
and i
had i never saw him since we didn't talk
things through and
before we had a chance to figure
anything out he filed
i don't know no and and that's why even
when i hear things about like things
christine and davina are saying about
what they think
i'm one of the closest people to
rachelle and i don't know it's not my
business
if she wants to tell me then she will
i don't ask because at the end of the
day it doesn't matter
i actually do know what it was about and
um i'm not going
to say it to be honest like it's it's
not
if she chooses to share it it's not
like somebody cheated or i mean it's not
even like
a huge it doesn't change the story
no no no it's like not even like a
life-changing
argument so mad at him but um
and for more than one reason i liked
that show damn it like i really liked
that show and now i can never watch it
ladies and gentlemen
you're going to ruin this is us for even
more people after this interview plus
is the name of the show sorry guys